i got white again that was lucky
shouldn't know that who that is i don't
so
i'm not in as in touch with the
good chest as i used to be but it's nice
a three minute game and um
and we'll see what happens
oh he plays this way
yeah i know it's gonna get very
theoretical
i'm not sure i like that
but i don't really have uh don't really
have a choice
it's really the uh the only way to
i does this
yeah this i just don't know at all
so yeah i have no idea what the
what the theory says here
i probably should but i don't
okay queen b3 back
knight a5 i'm gonna go queen b2
not gonna make a draw
quite yet drop back with the bishop
and i'm hoping to claim that after all
his lack of
well not castling rights but
[Music]
his difficulty in counseling is is an
important factor
so now i suppose i need to to play um
uh to play actively
no okay intention is queen king f7
knight e4 obviously
and um
then
hmm
c4 he goes f5
it's not that easy anyway i gotta go
faster
finding it surprisingly hard to crack
his position here
i feel like i should be be better but
it's it's not that easy
this i'm a bit suspicious of
leaving the
leaving the night out to dry on
an a5 suppose maybe you can get away
with it
yeah now i just need to play faster
just burning all my time i'm not finding
the solutions
preparing maybe 94 i don't know
queen c7 okay
my moves aren't particularly good but i
i cannot spend too much time anymore
so now i'm hoping if
okay this looks very suspicious
i think cbo on the move on the previous
move was also good but
now maybe it's just better
but i'm still doing i'm still doing very
well but time is starting to become an
issue
bishop d6 the idea is 94.
yeah so that's why it goes for this
you can take on basics they didn't he
didn't do that
i'm in serious danger of listening on
time here
queen before i like this
i feel like i'm getting some momentum
back
yeah now i just gotta play fast oh i
don't have auto queen that's a problem
my technique is a bit small just so slow
oh that was close wow